.
>> STANDBY, JEFFREY.
WE DO HAVE BREAKING NEWS JUST IN
TO CNN.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS ISSUED AND
THIS IS THE DECISION MANY R
WAITING FOR, RULING IN DOBBS
VERSUS JACKSON WOMEN'S HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
THE MAJOR CASE.
AS WE WAIT TO READ THIS
DECISION.
JEFFREY, PUT INTO CONTEXT HOW
CONSEQUENTIAL THIS IS.
>> PSYCHOLOGISTS HAVE A TERM
CALLED FLASHBULB MEMORY.
YOU REMEMBER WHERE YOU ARE WHEN
SOMETHING HAPPENED.
TODAY IS THE MOMENT WE WILL
LEARN THE FATE OF CONSTITUTIONAL
ABORTION RIGHTS IN AMERICA.
IN 1973, IS SUPREME COURT
DECIDE
ED ROE VERSUS WADE.
NOW THE DOBBS CASE INVOLVING A
STATUTE OUT OF MISSISSIPPI IS
WHETHER RIGHTS WILL CONTINUE.
THIS IS A ESPECIALLY BIZARRE
SCENARIO IN SUPREME COURT
HISTORY BECAUSE A DRAFT OPINION
OF THIS -- IN THIS CASE WAS
LEAKED ABOUT SIX WEEKS AGO
.
IT'S A HISTORICAL MOMENT.
>> STANDBY.
I WANT TO GET TO JESSICA
SCHNEIDER OUTSIDE OF THE COURT
WITH MORE.
JESSICA, WHAT IS THE OPINION
FROM THE COURT?
>> Reporter: THE COURT ISSUING
THAT LANDMARK RULING THAT THIS
NATION HAS BEEN BRACING FOR AND
THE SUPREME COURT HAS OVERTURNED
ROE V WADE.
THEY HAVE ELIMINATED THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO AN
ABORTION AND AT FIRST GLANCE
THIS OPINION IS VERY SIMILAR TO
THAT DRAFT OPINION THAT WE SAW
LEAKED ABOUT A MONTH AND A HALF
AGO AT THE BEGINNING OF MAY.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING AT FIRST
GLANCE HERE IS THAT THIS IS A
5-4 DECISION.
THIS IS AN OPINION WRITTEN BY
JUSTICE SAMUEL ALETTO JOINED
WITH THE OTHER CONSERVATIVES.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS
NOT JOINING IN THE OPINION BUT
JOINING IN THE JUDGMENT MEANING
HE AGREES THAT THE MISSISSIPPI
15-WEEK ABORTION BAN SHOULD BE
UPHELD BUT NOT AGREEING WITH
THERE SWEEPING PROCLAMATION THAT
ROE V WADE IS OVER TURNED.
WE'RE LOOKING INTO THIS OPINION
BUT THIS WILL HAVE IMMEDIATE
EFFECTS HERE.
BY ALL ESTIMATES ABOUT HALF OF
THE STATES ARE EXPECTED TO
ELIMINATE THE RIGHT TO ABORTION.
WE HAVE GOT ABOUT A HALF DOZEN
STATES THAT HAVE SO CALLED TRIG
ER LAWS THEIR ABORTION BANS WILL
GO INTO EFFECT IMMEDIATELY OR
WITHIN THE NEXT 30 DAYS OR NEXT
FEW MONTHS.
WE HAVE DOZEN STATES WITH ZOMBIE
LAWS.
THEY WERE ON THE BOOKS BEFORE
ROE V WADE THAT WILL GO BACK
INTO EFFECT.
ON THE FLIP SIDE, THERE ARE
ABOUT 16 STATES IN WASHINGTON,
D.C. THAT HAVE SORT OF AMPED UP
THEIR ABORTION PROTECTIONS.
THEY ARE EXPECTING POTENTIALLY
TO SEE AN INFLUX OF PATIENTS
COMING INTO THEIR STATES TO
ACTUALLY GET ABORTIONS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN
STATEMENTS THAT WILL SOON NOT BE
ABLE TO GET ABORTIONS.
THIS IS A LANDMARK RULING HERE.
THIS IS OVER TURNING NEARLY 450
YEARS OF PRECEDENT THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN ROE V WADE AND
AFFIRMED IN CASEY.
THOSE OPINIONS, THERE'S BEEN A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO AN
ABORTION FROM THE SUPREME COURT.
WOMEN HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET
ABORTIONS.
THE STATE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
RESTRICT ABORTIONS UP TO THE
POINT OF VIABILITY ABOUT 23 TO
24 WEEKS.
NOW THIS COURT UP ENDING THE
PAST 50 YEARS OF HISTORY.
LOOKING VERY SIMILAR TO THAT
DRAFT DECISION WRITTEN BY
JUSTICE SAMUEL ALETTO.
HE SAID THAT ROE V WADE WAS
EGREGIOUSLY WRONG.
IF IT SIMILAR, WHICH IT APPEARS
TO BE, HE'LL TALK ABOUT HOW
THERE'S NO HISTORICAL PRECEDENT
FOR THE SUPREME COURT UPHOLDING
THE RIGHT TO AN ABORTION AND
THIS SHOULD BE LEFT TO THE
STATES.
THIS IS WHAT THIS OPINION WILL
DO.
IT WILL SAY THIS CONSTITUTION
DOES NOT GUARANTEE THE RIGHT TO
ABORTION AND IT'S LEFT TO THE
INDIVIDUAL STATES.
ONE LAST THING, GUYS, JUSTICE
ALETTO SAID IN THE DRAFT WITHIN
AND PROBABLY SAYS IT, THIS IS
TOO DIVISIVE AN ISSUE TO KIND OF
GLEAN FROM THE CONSTITUTION WHEN
IT ISN'T SPECIFIC ABOUT ABORTION
AND A ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
ABORTION.
THIS NEEDS TO BE DECIDED BY
INDIVIDUAL STATES WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VO